skateboarding damit herzlich willkommen
meine lieben freunde zu einer longboard
modifikation beziehungsweise
skateboarding allgemeinen wakeboard sind
dabei penny bord sind dabei eine
overboard ist dabei ein segway ist dabei
und noch relativ viele andere sachen
ihr seht schon ich sitze hier die kugel
auf ja ich setze darauf und ja da ist
ein blog zwischen da läuft so ein
komisches kultur vor mir her
es wäre natürlich cooler wenn ich darauf
stehen würde das wäre richtig richtig
heiß allerdings wollte ich euch diese
ganze modifikation einfach mal näher
bringen es ist eine modifikation für die
micro version 1.6 punkt 4
also ja die ist nicht mehr allzu aktuell
allerdings ist das ganze work in
progress also das ist eine alte arbeitet
immer noch an der modifikation und
irgendwann wir die ganze dann
wahrscheinlich in einer beta oder in
einer kompletten version rauskommen für
die aktuellste version also für die 1.8
beziehungsweise 7.10
das ganze funktioniert und ob es in der
beschreibung ezb ich würde sagen ich
fange mit der vorstellung wir können uns
inventar gehen und gehen wieder eine
seite weiter
dann sehen wir item group skateboard mod
also da führen wir dann verschiedene
sachen energy drink von monster gerne
auch klamotten wie beispielsweise
einheiten shirt und skater shoes wir
haben auch eine richtig geile sandras
ist also richtig geile brille
die meisten sachen hier von dieser ihr
seht sind einfach nur um sich sondern
dinge selber zu kraft name
beispielsweise den truck
händel war es nochmal vettel ich bin mir
gar nicht so sicher das map pack so ganz
ganz viele verschiedene sachen
ich glaube ich auch noch was genau wenn
auch plastik plastic logic alles
mögliche um diese verschiedenen sachen
zu kräften allerdings meinte in den
letzten mottoshows aber mal so ein paar
leute leute jo die kräftige deshalb da
muss ja nicht unbedingt zeigen kann man
sich ja selber nachschauen im forum
deswegen hab ich euch den link und
reingepackt von der website wo außerdem
auch die crafting rezepte stehen und ich
zeige jetzt erstmal was diesem motto
alles hinzufügt was man alles machen
kann
also wir haben wir verschiedene dinge
wie beispielsweise nach action dann die
normale eine ganz normale und eine
funbox würde ich mal sagen dieses kate
bush das ist diese workbench quasi extra
für diese modifikation die kann man sich
dann extra craften damit man dann das
ist so eine drei mal sechs workbench
also so ein bisschen länglich wo man
dann extra solche sachen drin mit
kräften kann oder sowas und ich würde
sagen also erstmal diese ganzen crafting
rezepte findet ihr wir können das ganze
einfach hier irgendwo hinsetzen damit
das ganze dementsprechend wo wir
hinschauen hingesetzt und hier habe ich
auch schon so eine rampe als zusammen
gebaut wo man dann auch irgendwie
hochfahren kann es ist noch immer das
ganze wie ihr seht wenn ich zum beispiel
letzten läuft diese scheiß minecraft
musiker halt's maul das
geht immer so ein bisschen weg wenn er
links am rand guckt also das ist halt
alles noch eine alpha dann haben wir
beispielsweise die kicker
das ist eine etwas kleinere wo man so
darüber fahren kann auch sehr sehr nett
aber halt sehr sehr klein so er dass man
dann irgendwie darüber auf dann
irgendwie so ein händler
drauf fahren kann und darauf dann so ein
bisschen zu leiten kann oder so ein paar
sachen machen kann
und ja ich sehe jetzt hier
beispielsweise ich habe beispielsweise
dem metal support den habe ich hier
angebracht einfach damit es ein bisschen
cooler aus sieht die sache aus wenn man
denn die einfach nur so eine luft gehen
würde und dass hier sind
das sind ganze aber das hier ist derzeit
support die habe ich einfach direkt
darunter gebaut also beispielsweise wenn
ich jetzt hier eine rampe mal hin bauen
sollte so habe ich hier beispielsweise
erst mal haben wir den support hingebaut
damit das ganze so ein bisschen cooler
aussieht dann habe ich hier wieder die
rampen drauf gesetzt so und dann habe
ich immer so hunden haben jetzt noch
stabiler aussieht die hier unten dieser
hingesetzt
so fiel dann setzen wir wieder diese
zeit kacke hin so dass ich das ganze
nämlich so aus und dann setzen wir da
oben hier direkt drauf und dann als
allerletztes habe ich dann hier einfach
komplett im apple support sich das ganze
relativ cool hat also wir jetzt nicht
nur den apple support sondern dieses
zeitraums auch noch ich weiß nicht ob
ich noch eine andere funktion haben aber
ich habe es jetzt einfach mal so als
stütze quasi genommen
dann haben wir noch ganz viele andere
sachen wie beispielsweise die funbox
sieht das ist nicht die sache die mich
so ein bisschen stört da war kein
texture pack angegeben bei den bildern
über die modifikation in dem forum hat
man so dinge gesehen wie beispielsweise
dass das hier ist ein polizist also das
ist ein entity policeman der außerdem
auch auf einem segway herumfahren kann
also wir haben ja so ein paar sportler
wenn wir mal hier schauen jeder haben
wir beispielsweise segway overboard
skateboard segway police
zombie segway policeman und dann sehen
wir hier da sozusagen auf dem segway
drauf und fährt damit auch gleich rum
wenn wir mal ein bisschen anstupsen oder
sondern felder damit auch warum da sehen
war und die texturen fehlen halt das ist
finde ich ein bisschen traurig weil da
auch keinen text beck irgendwie
angegeben war so ein respekt was man
dafür nehmen könnte wenn jeder irgendwas
wirst woran das liegt dann schreibst auf
jeden fall in die kommentare weil es ist
es sieht alles sehr sehr cool aus und
auch wenn ihr das bild auf der website
mit dem polizisten auf dem segway sieht
das ganze sehr sehr ansprechbar aus und
das ist halt der einzige nachteil das
ganze noch nicht so richtig funktioniert
das ist halt noch in der alpha man kann
zum beispiel auch wenn ich mich hier so
ein hofer bord nehmen
richtig damit fahre ruckelt das ganze so
ein bisschen ab guck mal da ist er
andere politik von meinte ruckelt das
ganze noch ein bisschen doof wenn ich
beispielsweise diese rampe versuche
hochzufahren
dann fahre ich quasi so irgendwie durch
die rampe durch das einzige wo das ganz
gut funktioniert ist diese rampe da kann
man einfach so hochfahren
das ist ganz cool aber sonst ist diese
mod noch relativ pack ich wollte immer
zeigen dass jetzt gerade dieses cruiser
bord so damit können wir auch mal
irgendwie so rum fahren wir können jetzt
ein paar tricks machen hier so mal drauf
stellen und allemal drin also das ganze
funktioniert noch nicht so richtig
ich kann nachvollziehen wenn ihr der am
ort einen daumen runter gibt aber es ist
halt so ich wollte euch die mode einfach
zeigen weil sehr viele coole sagen
zugeführt werden wir haben hier ein
keyboard mit dem wir auch mal und da
kann man damit so ein paar skills machen
ganz cooler wäre das ganze noch wenn ich
dann wirklich irgendwie hier drauf an
könnten dann wird er hier so drüber zu
leiten und so dass wir an einnahmen
aller ganzen das finde ich richtig
richtig cool und was ich da ein bisschen
traurig finde ist dass er dinge
hinzugefügt hat gewässer münzautomat wo
man aber nicht darauf zugreifen kann
das ist das ist sondern das ist dann so
eine wendige maschine also ein
münzautomat wo man sich eigentlich so
getränke holen kann und so oder anders
bin wo ich nicht irgendwie was
reinwerfen kann oder auch wenn ich da
was dran schweizer dann liegt halt nur
drauf und dann nehme also das bringt
ihnen nichts nur so zu
verschönerung des ganzen und hier fehlen
halt auch wieder die texturen das ganze
ist ein bisschen traurig was mich so ein
bisschen an der modifikation stört was
allerdings wieder cool ist ist dass
dinge zugefügt werden wie ein held ein
shirt penn state uci skate ist wie man
selber abspielen kann das heißt wir
nehmen uns hier einfach mal so haben wir
denn da haben wir den meter soweit das
überhaupt noch ist es nicht dass
tatsächlich ein notebook in was man das
ansprechen können das war kein roboters
ist ein wo ich mir noch doof nämlich
music tisch wie nennt man nochmal dieses
teil wo man die eine jukebox genau
reinschmeißen die musikerin ein bisschen
an
[Musik]
hallo wie geht das jetzt gar nicht
möchtest nicht abspielen
okay der will das hat nämlich abschnitte
weinig kommt auf so eine coole musik
dann sollte so groupies cajun music
irgendwie funktioniert es gab mit dem
notebook nicht keine ahnung dass wir da
dieser dieser der zombie zombie segway
möchtegern sparst du gehen und ja es
werden halt dinge hinzugefügt umsonst
gate park zu bauen also beispielsweise
haben und hier diese dieses teil
diese gebogene rampe
skateboard schild müller immer ganz
viele verschiedene sachen worauf man
tricks machen kann allerdings
funktioniere nicht halt nicht man kann
auf jeden fall ein super kombi skatepark
bauen um das einzige richtig
funktionierte zum longboard mit dem man
richtig schnell unterwegs sein kann
also das ist richtig nein zu sehen hat
mich quasi an so ein pferd weil man kann
damit wirklich auch hier diese blöcke
hochfahren und so also das ist echt ne
überlegung wert dass man damit dann so
ein bisschen unterwegs sein kann
das ist echt ganz neues aber diese ganze
mod ist halt so ein bisschen noch in der
alpha phase und der entwickler arbeitet
daran und seid nicht allzu böse mit
ihrem mann kann sich hier auf jeden fall
auch die sachen aufsetzen ich will es
derzeit so aus ich hab auch eine gold
schäme ich das mal anschaut da sieht man
mal ein bisschen habe ich so ein sondern
seine kette um kann ich mir stattdessen
aber auch ein t shirt anziehen und
anstalt an statt der glas das kann ich
mir dann noch ne coole die glas ist
sagte riegler ist auch ich talent kann
mir so einen coolen hält hier aufsetzen
und die richtige skaterbahn und ja also
ein paar coole dinge werden hinzugefügt
das ganze ist noch in der alpha seid
nicht allzu böse
wir haben also ein paar gerät mit dem
erfahren können aber das einzige was
quasi richtig funktioniert ist das
richtige skateboard mit dem ich gerade
fahrer und das longboard beim rest
ruckelt das ganze immer noch so ein
bisschen segway ist auch so ein bisschen
komisch zu fahren also dass ruckelt
extrem so von a nach b
aber ich denke der entwickler ist auf
coolen weg und die motten die mod hat
potenzial und ich wollte euch einfach
mal zeigen was ich mir quasi wünschen
würde ist wenn er im text angeben würde
weil das kann ja nicht sein dass solche
fehler sind
oder habe ich hier irgend ein falsches
gut ausgebildete ich habe default
ausgewählt also ich weiß nicht wieso da
irgendwelche fehler auftreten da kann
keiner erklären und was ich mir noch
wünschen würde ist seine anstatt dieses
ganze equipment hier wie so ein
skateboard im schild zu design mal
lieber sich darum kümmern würde dass das
ganze auch vernünftig funktioniert das
wäre auf jeden fall so eine sache die
mich noch davon überzeugen würde mit
dieser macht regelmäßig zu spielen und
sonst würde ich sagen was es mit dem
motto stellen wenn es euch trotzdem
gefallen hat dass ich euch solche mods
vorstelle auch wenn sie noch nicht so
ganz gut funktioniert aber trotzdem
einfach mal zeigt doch was für ein weg
wir sind und dass die leute dann
eventuell schreibt soja coole
modifikationen vielleicht machen sie
denn er weiter dann zeigt es mit einer
bewertung und sonst würde ich euch sagen
heute abend kommt noch die minecraft
wenn ich genug zusammen kriege und dann
sehen wir uns heute abend wieder